déjà à plus d'une centaine de communes
en france aujourd'hui n'ont plus d'eau
potable et pour lequel il ya des
approvisionnements qui se font avec de
locon achemine en camion dans ces
communes puisqu'il ya plus rien
effectivement dans les canalisations
tout l'enjeu c'est de durcir un certain
nombre de restrictions pour éviter d'en
arriver là sur les territoires on
s'aperçoit qu'on a des déficits
hydriques qui se prolonge et puis être
capable d'anticiper parce que si vous
devez aller fournir de l'eau il faut pas
vous en préoccuper le matin où il ya
plus d'eau et canalisations donc il ya
un travail d'anticipation avec les
préfectures qui est animé par cette
cellule interministérielle de crise